[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMY SCHULZ: So thank you.
So here we have the
cast and creative.
So wouldn't you go down the
line and introduce yourselves
and let us know what role
you play in the show.
LAUREN YALANGO GRANT: I
am Lauren Yalango Grant,
and I am in the "King's"
company and ensemble.
PETER ENGLAND:
I'm Peter England.
I'm scenic designer and
projection designer.
GAVIN ROBINS: Hello,
Gavin Robbins.
I'm the movement
director for "King Kong."
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: Hello,
I'm Carmen Pavlovian,
and I'm the producer
of "King Kong."
SONNY TILDERS:
I'm Sonny Tilders,
and I'm the creature
designer of "King Kong."
JON HOCHE: My name is Jon Hoche.
I am one of the voodoo
puppeteers for "King Kong,"
and I am also the
voice of King Kong.
AMY SCHULZ: Great.
So "King Kong" was
first introduced in 1933
by filmmaker Marian C. Cooper.
And The story continues to be
told in different variations,
and now "King Kong" has
taken over Broadway.
First time ever on stage.
So who came up with
the initial idea of,
I think a "King Kong"
should be on stage?
Where did this start?
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: Well, I
think the answer ultimately
depends on whether "King
Kong" is a success or not.
If it is, I'm going
to say it was my idea.
And if it's not, I'm going to
say it is Peter England's idea.
Full disclosure-- we're married.
And when we were setting up
Global Creatures back in 2007,
we were in London and
thinking about ways
that we might use this
extraordinary animatronic
capability that Sonny Tilders
here is the brains behind.
And Sonny and his team had
built lifelike dinosaurs
for an earlier
production of ours called
"Walking With Dinosaurs."
And I was about to
set up this company,
and I was thinking about ideas
for how we might utilize this
for another theatrical show.
And so Pete and I
were in our apartment
in London chatting about
ideas, and in many respects,
it's not a great leap to come
up with the idea of doing "King
Kong" when you're
thinking about how
you might utilize that kind
of animatronic technology.
On the other hand,
as soon as we went,
won't that be a crazy idea?
What started to dawn on
us was the possibilities
of storytelling, because
"Walking With Dinosaurs"
had been an arena show.
And what "King Kong" lent
itself to, of course,
because it's such an
epic myth, and it's
a production of such scale
that we thought music
could have a really
interesting role there.
And so we asked ourselves
this question about
whether or not the
show could exist
in a more traditional
proscenium-style theater.
And so from there, we started
this really quite bizarre
process of what I
call proof of concept
where Pete and Sonny had to
really think about, well,
if we put a creature that
size in a limited space
of a theater, how does
he get on and off?
How does he do that
in an interesting way
where we're not seeing him just
sort of shuffle into the wings?
Can he fit in the wings?
Sonny, can you
make sure that when
he swipes his arm that
he's not going to knock out
the whole ensemble?
And could Sonny create something
where he could scratch his nose
or beat his chest
without putting
a fist through his sternum?
And Pete, of course, had
to think about, well,
once that creature's
taking up the space, how
do I put a set in there?
Et cetera.
So that's how we began.
AMY SCHULZ: Was it always
going to be a musical?
Or maybe a play?
What made you want to put music
and dance with it as well?
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: Well, sorry,
I won't answer every question,
but I will just take this one.
So we knew because
of scale that music,
because of, obviously, its
capacity to evoke emotion,
and it was very important to us.
And I'm sure you'll hear
more from Sonny and Gavin
in terms of Kong as a
creature and a creature
that we connect with.
It was a very important
part of our development
that we weren't making a
robotic creature that you'd
expect to see at a Universal
Theme Park ride or something,
that we actually were making
a creature that could be part
of a story that
moved you and helped
you use your imagination
as an audience member.
We didn't think, oh, let's
make "King Kong-- the Musical"
because, let's be frank,
that sounds quite comedic.
We just nonetheless
thought that music was just
going to be important to
give us scale and emotion.
And as time went on,
one thing we really
wrestled with in the
creative development
was that we had this
extraordinary creature who
really did work and function as
a character onstage interacting
with humans, but we just kept
feeling like no matter what
we did, this creature
was plugged in the middle
of someone else's musical.
And eventually, we
realized that we
had to honor this incredible
conceit that Sonny
and the team and Gavin had come
up with of Kong being operated
by puppeteers, and humans move
him around and breathe life
into him.
And that that idea, if we pulled
it through the entire show,
would give us the kind of
cohesion we'd been looking for.
So it got me thinking that the
pages of this particular story
really needed to be turned with
a physical language to match
Kong's.
So then, we started
working with Drew McOnie,
because he's a choreographer
and a director.
And his idea was to have a
cast that could puppeteer
the whole set through movement.
And that became
really fundamental
to the whole musical
identity of the piece
as well, because of course, this
sounds so simple and obvious
now, but we didn't
initially really get
to grips with the fact that
King Kong is the leading
character in a musical, but
he can't sing and can't speak
and he can't dance.
And as much as people always
say, oh, does the monkey sing?
He doesn't sing.
And so we needed
to find something
in the language of
the storytelling that
really paid deference to
the type of performer he is.
So went the music.
PETER ENGLAND: When Cooper
made that film in 1933,
it was really the first
Western, at least,
movie with a
purpose-built score.
And so it has a
musical identity that
is critical to a lot of what
that movie's success was.
And being such an epic, almost
legendary mythological-type
tale, a "Beauty and the
Beast" kind of archetypal fear
of monsters and journeying
from one empire, New York City,
to this fallen empire
and this mythical island,
giant boat trip and climbing
up a mountain and coming back
to New York City and then
climbing the tallest point,
the Empire State Building--
there's something about
that storytelling,
which is verging on operatic.
And music is one of the
great international languages
of storytelling, in a way.
And it supports that epic
journey, perhaps better
than simple words would do.
So I think that's just part
of the drive of the production
is a musical language as
opposed to being a musical.
AMY SCHULZ: And the story
was created in 1933,
and your story is
set in 1933 too.
Was there any thought about
making it contemporary
or putting it in
the 21st century?
PETER ENGLAND: In
that a modern audience
needs to take
something away which
means something to them,
but not in contemporizing
it to put it--
like Dino De Laurentiis
did his 1976 film
and set it on the Twin Towers.
And he was going for a
very contemporary angle
on the story.
For us, the idea of 1933--
the Great Depression,
the building
of the Empire State Building
in 13 and a half months--
these sorts of things are
really at the heart of the story
that we've been
trying to tell, which
is about a gritty courage and
ambition that defies the odds.
And there's something
about that period
in this city that captures
that in a very poetic way.
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: I might
add that when we were first
thinking about this
show, it was 2008
when we were doing our
creative development,
when that process began.
And we were about six
months in, I think,
when you had the financial
markets crash here,
which spurned on the
global financial crisis.
And we were so struck by
it because, of course,
through our development
process by day,
we were researching New York of
1933 and the Great Depression,
and then often saying, my god.
At night, our televisions
were on with news broadcasts,
and all anyone was talking about
was these financial crisis not
seen on a scale since the
Great Depression of the '30s.
And I just thought, wow, this
story does need to be told.
And in thinking about
what stories one
might put on the stage, there
has to be a reason to do it.
And you might notice
if you consume
arts editorial at
the moment, there's
a lot of frustration on behalf
of a number of reviewers
of films just being
plumped on stage.
And of course, "Kong"
is not just a film.
It's one of the great
myths of the century.
Originally, it was
a novella in 1932
that came out as a
publicity tool for the film.
And of course, it's been
told in many forms since.
And so the question
we asked ourselves
is, what can this story say
that's new to an audience
today?
And well, at the
time, we didn't think
it's going to take 10 years
to realize the production,
but along the way, every
step of the journey, what's
been really particularly
noticeable to me
is that there's
something that's always
relevant in current
events of the day.
So "King Kong"
essentially is a story
about a beauty and the beast.
Historically in
this country, it's
really had a lot of debate and
thinking about racial overtones
and subtext in the piece.
So we had to think about that.
Of course, there's
climate change.
There's the idea
of the other, which
is a really important
part of our story telling.
And of course, we have a
filmmaker, Carl Denham,
who's threatening to crush a
young actress if she doesn't
do what he wants
to do, because he's
one of the most powerful
producers on Broadway,
apparently.
And so, of course, we
were having these scenes
read during
auditions at the time
that the Harvey Weinstein
scandal broke, and I just
thought, wow.
Here we go again.
Everything we do
around "King Kong"
seems to find a relevance
in what's happening today.
So that was important
to us, but we really
felt rooting it in a 1933 period
was important because to us, it
really started to answer the
question of why something that
was created in 1933 still
has something relevant to say
to audiences today.
But we wanted to not have it
feel like a very traditional
musical, so it was important
to us that we found a language
that honored the
'30s, but still had
it feel like there was a level
of innovation and something
contemporary that you could
see in the whole aesthetic
of the piece that carries
through the music as well.
AMY SCHULZ: And so Sonny,
you are the creator,
the designer of this.
So I read King Kong the
puppet is 20 feet tall
and he's 2000 pounds.
Where does one begin to
design something of that size?
SONNY TILDERS: It's
certainly an evolution,
and as Carmen
described, we really
evolved this out of
"Walking With Dinosaurs."
And I think the
instinct was probably
to do something like "Walking
with Dinosaurs," where
we made these lovely,
very realistically wrought
creatures.
And that's where we started.
And we thought, well, I'll just
make this lovely robotic thing,
and we'll try and get
that sublime realism
that we saw in the Peter
Jackson film of 2004.
And I thought, that
would be a thrill
to get that level of
animatronics on the stage.
But then, we
realized it would be
a bit of a rod for our backs.
Not least, how do
we make this what
would be probably a
substantially heavier piece
of equipment work
on stage safely?
It would be like having an
earth digging machine on stage
with actors.
You wouldn't you wouldn't
let anyone near it.
So that killed that idea.
And then working with Pete
on the production design
side of things, it was
clear that Pete's not
going to make a slavishly
realistic version of New York.
He's going to use all
the tricks of theater.
And it really dawned on
us that it made no sense
to do something so realistic.
Now, people say
Kong's realistic,
but he is quite aesthetically
different or pushed,
if you like.
His proportions are quite
superhero proportions.
He doesn't have fur.
He has a bunch of these things
that we wanted to take him
somewhere else so that
the audiences is doing
a bit more work rather
than just sitting there
passively and watching
something so realistic.
AMY SCHULZ: It's interesting
that you say that,
that he doesn't
have fur, because I
could have sworn he did.
Being in the audience
and seeing him,
it just seemed so lifelike.
SONNY TILDERS: Yeah, and the
fur was one of those things
that, as soon as
we put fur on him,
he started to look far
too realistic again.
And we tried all sorts of
different versions of string
and shade cloth, and
whenever we did it,
it just looked
like a shaggy dog.
And we had this
lovely sculptural form
as a sort of a mannequin to
try out these various surfaces,
and the sculptural form was
made of these muscle bags.
And one of the
lovely things that we
do as a company at
Creature Technology
is to try and make
creatures look a sublimely
real as possible, and that is
about making anatomical layers.
So the skin of dinosaurs,
usually scaly skin,
would sit on this
muscular under structure.
And so we'd always cover
this muscular under structure
that would stretch and
contract and change shape
like real muscles do, and
we'd pin up all this fur
and then take it off,
and then just sit
back and admire this
incredibly strong muscular form
and go, oh, that's it.
This epitomizes
what it culminated
to be-- this incredibly powerful
manifestation of masculinity.
But there's something kind
of lovely and vulnerable
about the rawness, too,
of not having a surface.
And so I think what Kong has
become is a moving sculpture,
and all his muscles
connect seamlessly.
But the trick is, it's
a marionette puppet,
so none of the joints
could have friction.
We needed this
freedom of movement
with a marionette puppet,
because essentially it's
strings that hold up
the arms, and they
need to be manipulated
by performers as well.
So there are a bunch
of technical challenges
to work through.
But the decision to have
him hairless, again,
evolved out of this
thinking about, well,
we've just got to remove him
from this slavishly realistic
thing.
Because, I think, with a puppet,
the form and the aesthetic
has to match the movement.
And there was a
concern, going back
to the idea of making it
a really realistic robot,
is that we'd probably
get it 90% right.
But that 10% would be the
difference between people
believing it or not.
So the marionettes-- very
traditional technique
with a less realistic aesthetic.
I think those two ideas
work well together.
AMY SCHULZ: And so
Gavin, you choreographed
the aerial movement of Kong.
And Kong isn't scenery.
Like he is moving
across the stage,
he's up and down, in the air
like an actor on the stage.
How long does it take to
choreograph a puppet and also
the people that control
the puppet to move as one?
GAVIN ROBINS:
Yeah, well, I mean,
we worked in Australia--
we did several workshops
on prototypes of Kong before
we ended up with this version.
And that was a very
informative process
where we worked originally
with circus artists
to try to find a
way of rigging Kong
in the points in
which Kong is attached
with marionette operation.
That took trial and error.
And we also had very
talented circus artists
that would have a knowledge of
working with ropes and strings.
And one of the things I
think we're really proud of
is the physical risk taking that
the performers involved, where
they jump off Kong's
shoulders at times
and haul his arms into
the air to swap the planes
or to fight the serpent
and this kind of thing.
So we had a lot of
exploration with
highly-trained
physical performers
and how that could intersect.
And so then, when we
were in Melbourne,
we worked for six months
writing automation cues,
and we have really
talented team--
Richard Martin, who writes a lot
of the automation programming.
It's the real connection
between automation,
the animatronics that Sonny's
created, the movement of Kong,
and the confluence of
all the performers action
that Lauren's a part of.
So it took a lot
of trial and error,
and then there's moments where
the voodoo and the movement
of the head coincides with
the movement of the shoulders,
and then the
placement of the hand,
and that took months
and months to create.
And with--
AMY SCHULZ: So all of
that is choreographed?
GAVIN ROBINS: It's
all choreographed.
AMY SCHULZ: Every
little step in order.
GAVIN ROBINS: And
everything has an impact.
So the way in which
the automation
moves, the way in
which the head moves,
the way in which the
shoulders, and then
the placement of the elbow
line, and all of these things.
There's so many
elements involved,
and you can get it wrong
very quickly, very easily.
And so it's about the
refinement of those things.
And even now in the
theater, we're writing,
we're adjusting cues.
There's a team in
there taking notes
that Sonny and I've given to try
to refine the movement of Kong
even more.
So yeah.
CARMEN PAVLOVICH:
So Gavin and Sonny,
is it worth you explaining
a little bit about what
voodoo technology is?
Because, of course,
it's the thing
that delivers all of the
emotion in Kong's face.
And you've always talked about
the importance of the puppet
breathing.
SONNY TILDERS: Yeah, so it
is an absolute combination
of a whole bunch of groups
of people, if you like.
And whilst much of it
is automated in terms
of Kong's position on stage--
and Kong is
essentially suspended
by what we call Kong's
apparatus, which is this--
it's like a gantry
crane above him,
which has this disk which
houses all the winches that
hold his 2000 pounds.
That part of it, because
of the safety aspect,
is automated and pre-programmed.
But the rest, 90%
of it is all live.
And so it's that concert
of all these live things
coming together every night
and getting to that point
where it's all working together
to create this sense of one
sentiment being on stage.
That's the beauty, I
think, that we really,
really enjoy bringing
to the stage.
But the voodoo aspect--
we call it voodoo--
there's three puppeteers
who operate all
the internal functions of Kong.
So Kong has a very
expressive faces.
There's about 16 servos
or motors in the face that
deal with his expression.
There's a bunch of hydraulic
axes for the more powerful
aspects within his body--
shoulder shrugs and
waist movements.
There's even pneumatics
in his wrists.
We found as a big
marionette puppet
where, I described before,
he needed lovely loose joints
for them to be manipulated when
Kong would go up and do a chest
beating.
In one of the
prototypes, his wrists
would flop around,
because they're out
of the reach of the performers.
It wasn't exactly powerful.
So it gets all quite anatomical.
We have these things
called air muscles, which
are a bit like tendons
in your forearm,
go around the wrist of Kong.
And they can be tightened
to make the wrist powerful,
or loosened so that
performers can manipulate them
and can flex and do a
range of things like that.
So there's a whole raft
of different technologies.
So we needed to find
a way of controlling
that sort of technology.
And so we took a leaf out of
the "Walking With Dinosaurs"
project that we worked on where
we had these voodoo operators.
And the name suggests whatever
you do with a voodoo doll,
the real thing does.
So that's where it leaps from.
We've used it in
film quite a bit.
We didn't coin the name.
But so there's three people
who have these voodoo rigs,
and Jon's one of them.
And Jon specifically
controls the neck of Kong.
So the eyeline of Kong,
where Kong's looking.
Danny controls the face, which
is this mix of expressions.
And Jacob--
AMY SCHULZ: Control
it with a joystick?
SONNY TILDERS: Yeah,
they're custom controllers.
So we try and make it is
intuitive as possible.
But we actually found
it quite hard with Kong
to make them match
some sort of anatomy.
So yeah, to get on
Danny's rig, which is--
they all look a bit like--
well, Danny's rig looks
a bit like a machine gun.
AMY SCHULZ: He does the face?
SONNY TILDERS: And
he does the face.
And so none of those things seem
to line up, so you get on them
and you're completely lost as
to what you're controlling.
So part of the challenge
I'm sure Jon will attest to
is breaking down all
these complex moves
and doing this
isolation training
so that you know that whatever
you're doing with the wrist
here, which is controlling
about five different functions,
that you understand
what you're doing.
AMY SCHULZ: I had
a question for Jon.
So there's three
of you doing that.
How do you work together?
Or do you work together?
Or do you just know that
you control the neck,
so Kong has to move
his neck, and then
Danny knows how
to move the face?
Or how does it work?
JON HOCHE: Well, we all have to
definitely work together to--
Kong in himself is
an ensemble piece.
No one person can
stand out, really.
You really have
to work together.
For example, like with doing the
voice, there is about an eighth
of a second delay
from what I'm doing,
so then Danny, who
is to my right,
can hear and anticipate what
I'm about to do onstage,
in essence.
So then he can create that.
AMY SCHULZ: I assumed you
did the facial expressions
because you're doing the voice.
So that's very interesting
to me that someone else
is going the voice, and
so when you do the scream,
he then manipulates--
JON HOCHE: Correct, yeah.
The face, with so many
servos and everything,
I think, is such a complex thing
that needs to be focused on--
SONNY TILDERS: Also, Jon,
the voice and the head
really lead the
intention of the puppet.
So it's really important that
Jon has those two things.
So where the puppet looks
and how it vocalizes
is the lead for the
other puppeteers,
and really for
the whole ensemble
to understand what the
brain of Kong is thinking.
So those things seem a
bit odd to bunch together.
Then again, the face
really is so complex
that to think about all
those nuances in the face
and do the voice, I
think, was probably
going to be an overloading
element for the puppeteers.
AMY SCHULZ: And how
choreographed or scripted
is the breathing and the
roaring and the grunting
that Kong does?
Do you know at certain cues that
you breathe or when you grunt,
or is it a new
performance every night?
JON HOCHE: There are
moments of improv
that happen every night, because
every night is different.
That's the beauty
of live theater.
But a lot of the grunts and
the growls, snarls, and roars
are all scripted.
He has lines, just like any
other actor has in the script.
And it's a mixture of almost
having not only a script,
but also a score,
too, because you
have to hit certain inflections
and things like that.
So it's half improv,
half have scripted.
AMY SCHULZ: And so Lauren, you
are part of the King's company
that control the
movements of the arms.
So can you talk a little
about your role specifically?
LAUREN YALANGO GRANT:
I bounce around a bit.
I'm on his elbow, I'm
on his right back foot,
and I'm also a person that does
some launching off of his back.
GAVIN ROBINS: She
does heroic launches.
Dun dun dun!
LAUREN YALANGO GRANT: For
us, as King's company,
it's really important
to-- obviously,
it's quite an ensemble piece.
No one is more important
than anyone else.
It's very much a group effort.
And also, what we do is
very much choreographed.
But Kong feels alive.
He's alive.
Like alive on Broadway-- he
really is alive on Broadway.
And so it's choreographed,
but there's also
moments where maybe automation
is delayed a little bit.
So we always have to be
really on high alert and ready
to be flowing and to adapt to
what's actually happening live
on stage, because it's
not always the same.
So we have to have our
antenna on high alert.
AMY SCHULZ: And
there's 10 of you.
LAUREN YALANGO GRANT: There
is 10 of us on stage, yeah.
AMY SCHULZ: And so do each
of you-- like you said,
you do wrist and the elbow.
Is everyone split up amongst
the different body parts?
Can you switch roles, or does
everyone know every part,
or do you only know
how to do the wrist?
LAUREN YALANGO GRANT:
For instance, there's
two guys that do the
paws, and they're
pretty much set in that role.
Same with the wrist gentlemen.
They're basically just there.
The back, we have the people
on the feet and knees,
we have a little
bit more flexibility
on what we're doing.
Like me and the other female
that's in King's company,
we do a few different
things, which
is kind of nice because you get
to know the creature even more.
So there are some parts
that are pretty stationary,
and then a few of us
bounce around and do
a few different tasks on him.
AMY SCHULZ: And then are there
understudies like if someone
injures themself?
LAUREN YALANGO GRANT:
Yeah, definitely.
We have three male swings
in King's company and one
female swing.
So they're amazing.
And from the beginning, they
were very much included.
It was a group effort.
Tackling this beast is
quite an undertaking,
and from the
beginning, we were all
hands on and trying
to get everyone
as knowledgeable and physical
with the puppet as much
as we can, because he's a beast.
AMY SCHULZ: And that set itself
that Peter designed is also
this moving majestic
piece as well.
Like in the beginning
of the story,
the Empire State
Building is growing
amidst the Great Depression,
and at the same time,
we see the character
Ann Darrow, who
is also trying to
rise out of the ashes
and make something of
herself in the world.
Can you talk about
how the Empire State
Building-- that building and
the city's architecture-- how
central that was to your design?
PETER ENGLAND: Can I
just also point out
that the King's company
don't just operate Kong,
but they are the most
amazing collection of dancers
I've ever seen in my life.
They also do all of
the ensemble dancing.
So it's a big night for them.
It's just-- it's amazing.
As Sonny said, when we
started working together,
to do a show like this, to
be literal and naturalistic
on a stage, we
would be scuttled.
So we need to use all of
the devices and, I suppose,
imagination that theater brings.
And just as Kong is,
in a way, something
of a sketch of a giant
gorilla, in that it's not
completely detailed,
anatomically correct--
as real as the
experience that you
feel that you've
had when you see
the show is, when you
see that creature,
he is sculptural and stylized.
And I guess that's the
same language that I've
used for the show scenically.
The building of the
Empire State Building--
I just constantly am fascinated
that that architectural icon
was built in 13
and a half months.
I just find that amazing.
AMY SCHULZ: During
the Great Depression.
PETER ENGLAND: Yeah.
Can't renovate a
kitchen in that time.
So the images of the metal
workers, the steel workers
1,000 feet up in the air
hanging off I-beams and hooks.
Referred to as sky
walkers at the time.
There's something about those
people at that height building
that building in the midst
of the Great Depression
that I found really inspiring.
It sounds odd, but
that's basically
what New York City has
become in this show.
It's I-beams and cables.
So Kong's got a lot of
ropes and cables connected,
and as does the set.
The main parts of
the New York City set
are all, in a sense,
marionette pieces themselves.
We quote directly from those
iconic images of the sky
walkers hovering up in the air.
In a way, we look at
our journey for meaning.
And at the beginning
to when we are,
we do have a nod to the
building of the Empire State
in the opening of the show.
Our journey takes
13 and 1/2 months.
So at the end of the show, she
climbs that building with Kong.
I suppose the other thing to be
said is the jungle part of it.
And that, I suppose,
is even more stylized
and more imagined.
It doesn't delve into forestry.
It's much more a state
of mind, in a way.
It's quite a
surreal environment.
It's got a hypnotic feel to
it, but the visual language
is all about vines.
So again, we're referencing
this idea of ropes,
and there are characters
who manipulate those vines.
So again, we're just
having this interaction
between cast and
physical objects in a way
to puppetry the environment,
to puppeteer Kong.
And there's actually
a time where
there are some performers that
are puppeteering our cast.
So the cast are manipulated
through the jungle
by the jungle.
So we've got layers and layers
and layers of that sort of rope
and cable language.
With the I-beams
in New York, we're
looking at the
skeleton of a city.
In a way, Kong also has some--
he's got a beautiful
climbing frame
when he's back, which
has a skeletal feel.
It has a nice nod to the
idea of a silverback gorilla,
being silver.
But I suppose the
aesthetic of this show
is to describe things
as simply as possible
using lines and skeletal
form to allow the audience's
imagination to do the rest.
The other big part
of it is where
we do lean on a much more
recognizable visualization
is the projection content.
So we have basically a
semicircle LED screen
that's 90 feet long by
almost 30 feet tall.
So it's a big
surface, and we create
a lot of our environments
and our sense of movement--
Kong's movement through a space,
a boat going through the ocean.
AMY SCHULZ: One of
my favorite visuals,
and that's including Kong in it,
but one of my favorite moments
was just the rocking of
the boat in the beginning.
The audience gasps, and that's
even before they've seen Kong.
You made us feel like
we were on this boat.
PETER ENGLAND: Yeah, I feel
good about that moment.
We've got a good boat.
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: He gets a
round of applause every night.
It's very good.
AMY SCHULZ: Yeah.
And how much of that is
the projection and your set
and then also the actors?
PETER ENGLAND: Actually,
the projection's
doing all the
movement work there.
AMY SCHULZ: Oh, really?
PETER ENGLAND: Yeah.
The boat is designed
to automate,
and we do do it once
when we first leave
the docks in New York City.
But we've found just the--
well, first of all, there's
some physical realities
that forecast dancing
around as energetically
as they are on a
rocking platform.
It's a bit tough
given everything else
they've got to do in the night.
But really, just the device
of having the boat profile
or silhouette shaped
skeleton and the moving
footage behind it is
enough to give you
the sensation of movement.
And then there are moments
where choreographically, there's
an engagement with
that movement as well.
And certainly,
Kong, we take that
to the extreme, where if he goes
running through an environment,
we can support that
with projection
and accentuate his physical
speed and dynamic using
that device.
And the projection,
like the scenery,
is also, whilst
it's recognizable,
it's intentionally quite
painterly and stylized,
and also as pushed
to the background
as it can be when
it needs to be,
rather than being some
sort of photographic tour.
CARMEN PAVLOVICH:
Can I add something
about the challenge
of the jungle?
Which the question of
aesthetic really preoccupied us
for quite a long time.
Because in 1933, telling a
story of a group of white people
going to an island, and in
that version of the story,
Ann was captured
by natives, and how
you represent that idea and
that kind of location in 2018
obviously was the topic of
some thinking and debating
from all of us.
In the end, Jack
Thorne decided he
didn't want to have natives
in this story, which
was a relief to all
of us, because he felt
he couldn't tell their story.
And so the question
became, how do
you represent Skull Island in
a satisfactory way in 2018?
So for us, it became very much
about an island that was--
I think you use
the word hypnotic,
Pete-- that it vibrated
of its own energy,
where it had sentient plants.
And it's like the
island's alive and has
its own kinesthetic
energy, but there's
no natives in this story.
And so just the
aesthetic of that.
We often think of this story
being told in four chapters.
It's the New York of the 1930s,
the boat journey at sea, Skull
Island, and then
all those elements
returning with the adventurers
to a different New York
in Chapter Four.
But I thought the visual
aesthetic of Skull Island
was a very interesting challenge
of this development as well.
AMY SCHULZ: Yeah.
I'm glad you brought that up
because I know when I watched
it and I knew the story, and
so I was wondering if there
were going to be natives.
And when you first
see the vines,
that's maybe what I
thought they were.
And it's really amazing
how they designed it.
And I don't know if it's
the movement of if it's
the choreography, but there are
actors dressed as the vines,
and they're jumping
on the actors,
and they're fighting them
off like they would fight off
a plant.
And it's pretty powerful.
And so then I realized,
oh, this is the island.
The island is the character.
The island is the native.
It's really great.
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: Excellent.
I'm glad you understood.
AMY SCHULZ: Yes.
PETER ENGLAND: But hopefully,
for a modern audience,
it just talks of nature.
It talks of an idea of some
sort of heart and ecology
that is trashed.
And that Kong sits at the
throne of that environment,
and by taking Kong
from that environment,
you intrinsically
take away its heart.
And so I think we've got
to the point of thinking,
you don't need people
to talk that idea
of cultural imperialism--
not to flog it, but just to
sort of put it out there.
You don't go into
these environments
and take something out without
suffering the consequences.
AMY SCHULZ: Well one
thing I wanted to ask,
Jon, and the rest
of you can too chime
in is, the most compelling
feature of Kong--
I mean.
His size is one thing,
but it's really his eyes.
And it's these dark eyes
and how expressive they are.
And his wonderment toward
Ann, and then also his just
sadness later when he's
trapped back in New York.
What do you feel
is the anchor that
connects the audience to Kong?
Is it his eyes or is it
your voice, your breath?
JON HOCHE: I would say
it's a mixture of both.
I think the beauty of
him is a lot of times,
people can look at him, and
whatever they're feeling
is reflected back at them,
especially in the eyes.
And when the light hits
the eyes just right,
they kind of glisten, and you
swear that they're moving.
But that's, I think, a testament
to the puppet and a testament
to the show and the script.
And yeah, sure.
The voice has a little
bit to do with that too.
But I can't take
full credit for that.
But yeah, I think it's just
what everyone has come together
to make this fully-realized
character in a musical
that Kong is really
speaks to people.
GAVIN ROBINS: And one of
the things that's important
when you're working with Kong
is that he's constantly alive.
I mean, the puppet can
die very quickly on stage.
And so the breath that's
happening through the movement,
but also the facial
expressions, the movement
of the nose, the energy of
the King's company on Kong--
all of that really
contributes to the sense
that he's constantly
thinking and feeling.
And that's really important.
AMY SCHULZ: It's
interesting that you
said that a puppet can quickly
die on stage, because you
see him pretty early on when
you get Kong to Skull Island.
And I admittedly was like,
oh, they already showed him.
But the amazement and
wonderment never goes away.
and I think that's
because of that.
He feels alive on the
stage, and you're just
learning more about
him throughout the rest
of the show.
SONNY TILDERS: Yeah,
and I think what
I like about it is each scene
refreshes our view of Kong
and then the way Kong
works with Peter's set.
Rarely do we repeat a
position or a move of Kong
throughout the whole show.
So yeah, we do expose
him relatively early,
earlier than originally.
It's evolved into
seeing him earlier,
because I think that's
what audiences wanted.
But there's so many different
variations in how we see him,
and I think that's
really important.
And there's of course his
emotional arc as well,
which, just to add to Jon's
comment about the face,
the face is
incredibly important.
And we had some big decisions
to make in terms of, OK, well
if we're embracing
marionette puppetry, which
is quite a traditional art form,
well then marionette puppetry
usually has a jaw that might
go up and down at most.
It may be a blinking
set of eyes.
But we were very
keen to make sure
that Kong was more
than just a snarling
based with a set of teeth
that might flash out every now
and then.
And so the expression
was something
that we thought was going to be
very important from the start.
And it speaks to this
idea and a certain mind,
but this idea that
puppetry is an incredibly
practical or pragmatic art form.
So all these choices
of whether to use
technology or humans
or ropes and strings
or hydraulic cylinder,
these were all
very pragmatic decisions.
And I think in the end,
they do the one thing
which is to create this
breath and life in the puppet.
Then audiences
that accept a grab
bag, if you like, of
different techniques,
as long as this one creation
is plausible at the end.
And so the expression was
one that we felt-- well
I certainly felt
quite comfortable
about putting this
layer of technology in.
And think it's really key
to Kong's emotional story.
AMY SCHULZ: He has so much
expression that I couldn't
believe what I was seeing.
It truly was unbelievable,
and it felt like it was--
I'm so used to
seeing CGI on film,
and that's what-- it seemed like
I was seeing CGI in real life.
It was just too realistic.
It was really great.
PETER ENGLAND: For
what it's worth,
think that the
puppeteers on stage
are the one
ingredient that really
gets that creature across
the line as a stage puppet.
And a lot of people
see it and say, oh,
why aren't we seeing
puppeteers moving around?
And a lot of people
may have seen
war horse, which was another
great example of seeing
puppeteers on stage.
And there's a long tradition,
bunraku and kabuki puppetry,
where you see the
puppeteers operating.
And the magic of theater where
you forego that device and just
surrender to the
imagination, and that those
puppeteers actually invest
him with a spirit and a soul.
Not to get religious about
it, but they really--
that contribution--
I'll tell you, if you see
the show, the curtain call
moment when they
step forward, it's
like an earthquake's
been going off.
There's a great appreciation
for what that device brings
to that puppet.
AMY SCHULZ: There is one
moment where Kong is gassed,
and the people controlling his
paw, they lay his paw down,
and then I saw that actor then
himself or herself do that.
And it was all seamless.
And as you said, you accept it.
Oh, so we have a question.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to say, I saw the show
and was absolutely
blown away, truly.
And I did want to say that
it almost felt interactive.
The audience felt-- it
was a communal feel.
They gasped, they cried, they
applauded all at the same time.
I just thought it
was phenomenal.
I also saw "Walking With
Dinosaurs," which is cool.
I didn't realize it
was the same team.
Yeah, so great job.
I don't have a question.
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: Oh, it's
nice to hear from you.
Thank you.
AMY SCHULZ: Do you
have a question here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I also saw it, and
I really enjoyed it.
I love the original
movie, and I think
that the show seems very
interested in like what
made that movie
powerful in a way that I
don't feel like every
adaptation of "King Kong" has.
And one of the things I
particularly enjoyed in it
was the collusion between Ann
and Kong towards the end of it.
It was like these scenes
of her riding on his back
as he is rampaging
through New York City.
And in the last song, they
paint him as less of a victim
and more as a kind of
Messiah figure of some kind
of liberation or something.
And I was wondering if
you could comment on some
of those character's choices.
Well, it was like replacing
Jack with Lenny, I think.
It did some interesting
things with the story.
I know none of you wrote
the book, I guess, but--
PETER ENGLAND: You said
no one read the book?
I've read that book.
AUDIENCE: No, wrote the--
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: No, we
didn't write the stage book.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: No, I
understand what you mean.
Jack Thorne is not amongst us.
Yeah.
So it's a great
question, because it's
been probably the most
central part of our thinking
over the last 10 years.
And it goes back a little to
my earlier point of why today?
What can this story offer
an audience in 2018?
And of course, if you think
about Ann Darrow in 1933,
she was a screaming blonde.
Kong was just a scary monster.
She was afraid of Kong.
They didn't become friends.
Later versions of the story
like the Peter Jackson film,
they had a friendship.
And in that original story, it
therefore made sense for there
to be a character
called Jack Driscoll who
was gallant and strong
and a ship's first mate.
And he could come and save
her from the scary monster,
and then they went off
into the sunset together,
and that felt like a
very satisfying story.
When we tried to include
the character of Jack
Driscoll in earlier
iterations of the show,
and this is before Jack
Thorne-- another Jack-- joined
us to adapt the book, we
found that Jack Driscoll
as a character was
always irritating.
Because when Ann and
Kong were together,
you're interested in them
and not really interested.
And it's just like, oh god, no.
He's here again.
And then when Kong
dies at the end,
it felt really awful
that suddenly he
walked out and embraced Dan.
And again, you
thought, oh, go away.
I don't want to hear
you say you love her.
I mean--
AMY SCHULZ: I hope everyone
knows the story of "Kong."
We've had so many spoilers.
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: Yeah.
And then the bigger question
for me over time-- harder
to answer-- is
what sends victory
at the end of this story?
And what does it mean when you
make a choice again in 2018
to say that we want
this to be end story?
We don't want this to be called
dead on the filmmakers story.
We want her to be
front and center,
and we want her to be the focus.
Well every time you try to
make the love interest matter--
and for us to care about
that subplot of Ann and Jack
Driscoll--
it only took the focus off
Ann, and it made it really hard
to keep her front of the story.
And I just thought
in 2018, I want
to have a female
protagonist on stage that
has a different
victory to walking off
in the sunset with a guy.
She had to change in some
way from the whole experience
of knowing Kong.
And so when I met
up with Jack Thorne
to ask him if he'd be
interested in writing it,
I put this to him and I said--
part of me is terrified to even
ask the question out loud--
is an audience going to want to
see a musical where there's not
the kind of romance or the
kind of musical opportunities
that a love interest offers you?
You can imagine some gorgeous
duet on the boat or at the end.
Is it just going to be boring
if it's about Ann and Kong.
And he said, absolutely not.
Let's never talk about it again.
Jack Driscoll has gone.
He complicates the
story, he's superfluous,
that's why he's
struggling, and you'll
find the storytelling just opens
up and becomes really clear.
AMY SCHULZ: The real love
story is between Ann and Kong,
and she does have a beautiful
ballad that she sings to him.
CARMEN PAVLOVICH: Yeah.
It's a real friendship of two
people who are misunderstood
and two outsiders.
So that was a really major
moment in our development.
It freed us up so much.
And Jack had one
other requirement
that he was very specific
about if he were to come
on board as the book writer.
He wanted this to be
a tale of ambition,
and he wanted Ann's ambition to
be a factor in Kong's capture.
Because he wanted to
see her fail in order
for her to go on the journey
and have this sort of victory
of becoming a better person,
or a different person,
from the experience.
Sorry, that was
very long answer.
AMY SCHULZ: That was great.
AUDIENCE: Can I just
quickly follow up
on a question about the
show and your casting?
And that if casting the
lead as a woman of color
was more about blind casting
and you're just like,
we love her voice.
We want her.
Or if it was to continue
telling that story
that you were just illustrating?
CARMEN PAVLOVICH:
Another great question,
because of course, this has
been another very big part
of our discussion.
And I mentioned
earlier, our thinking
about how one tells a
story about an island
with natives capturing
someone in 2018.
And the other piece
of it was Kong
does have a history
of alienating
some sectors of the community.
There's been a lot of
thought, and you can easily
find a lot of thought pieces
about whether Kong represents
the other and that the
whiteness in the stories
represents goodness.
And so we were interested
to subvert that.
The question of
colorblind casting
is very topical in our
industry at the moment.
And I find we
often talk more now
about color-conscious casting.
And I know Drew
McOnie, the director,
felt very strongly when
we talked about the piece
that we wanted it to be a show
that made everybody welcome
and that didn't alienate
anyone in the audience.
And to that end, it wasn't
about just saying, oh,
let's make sure that Ann's
just cast as a woman of color.
It was about really making sure
there was a level of diversity
through the whole company
and that the company we
put together reflects
a contemporary audience
and society today.
So that was an important
choice through the whole piece.
We auditioned a number of
women, of course, for Ann,
and we had a number of
other women of color
do previous workshops for us.
But the casting choice
itself ultimately
was based on the
person we thought
was the best for the role.
But we really did cast
our net very wide,
and it was a very
conscious choice
to do so, because we
wanted to reflect something
back to a modern
audience that looks
more the society we live in.
And we felt very strongly
about that choice.
AMY SCHULZ: Thank you so much.
And thank you all
of you for coming,
and thank you for coming.
And I think we have
to wrap it up here.
[APPLAUSE]